vous avez pris de bonnes résolutions
un groupe humain alors en france voici
l'interview bonnes résolutions de la
rentrée
olivia bonamy pour cette rentrée est ce
que vous avez décidé
d'arrêter de fumer
bon j'aimerais bien mais je suis une
petite fumeuse avance parce qu'en
général c'est juste des cigarettes de
plaisir d'accord
est ce que vous avez décidé de grossir
un peu pour donner une chance aux autres
filles quant à pascal à côté de vous ils
ont peu de chance
même si je mange beaucoup parce que je
manque beaucoup bon ben voilà ça me
prend pas toujours un peu la cua ouais
ça va
est ce que vous avez décidé de faire un
enfant ah oui ça de toute façon un jour
a pas cette année là
est ce que vous avez décidé d'arrêter de
vivre dans le péché non
vous avez décidé olivia bonamy cette
année de vous taper jean yves le fur
comme toutes les autres filles
[Applaudissements]
de vous taper jean yves le fur comme
toutes les autres films kiev ababou
connaissez pas encore mais non il s'est
tapé tout les gonzesses 1 toutes les
actrices je pense que ça ne se passera
pas comme ça se passera pas par an est
ce que vous avez décidé cette année de
prendre un nom très connu pour avoir des
rôles encore meilleur
est ce que
est ce que vous êtes décidé d'arrêter
les émissions de télé à la con
bon bah je suis ici ce soir donc donc
non et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
in a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux